大家好,我是吴言
唐秦安通道一直被誉为最好用的趋势跟踪指标
配合菲布拉切使用
可以精准的找到趋势中的入场点
让我们买在趋势的爆发点
卖在趋势衰竭处
我用Deepseek改进了以后
效果更好
接下来我将详细的分享我们的策略规则
大家可以先点赞和关注
以后不迷路
首先我们通过提示词工程
用Deepseek帮助我们生成了
这个唐秦安通道和这个菲布拉切的
这样一个代码
这个代码在这里
大家可以看到这个代码
在图表上验证
然后我们来主要看一下
它的这样一个核心策略
核心策略主要是做一个
通道突破的一个策略
就是通过我们的上下轨和中轨
的一个价格和颜色变化
包括飞不那切
给我们提供一个完整的入场点
那么这就是一个
我们的这样一个代码
那么它主要是通过
我们的这样一个突破的趋势的
这样一个策略
去做一个趋势跟踪
接下来我们直接在图表中
来给大家去验证一下
我们这个代码
不知道我们的图标里面
我们的这个规则是什么
好 首先我们来看一下做多的规则
那么做多的规则
我们的这样一个适用周期
我们是15分钟 30分钟和一个小时的
这样一个策略
首先我们来看做多规则是突破确认
我们价格由下向上突破中线
大家可以看到
我们的价格突破了这个中线
这个中线就是白色的这个线
突破了中线
然后趋势确认就是变成多头
趋势确认一定要就是蓝色线
那么这个蓝色的线就确认了我们这个趋势的多头
表示在更高的时间周期上
我们是向上的
然后我们的入场点是在哪里呢
我们的入场点就是价格突破中线以后
回踩在中线的下方
第一根这样一个菲波那切的这样一个位置
菲波那切的这个382的这个位置
然后获得支撑我们就可以入场了
然后这个点我们是可以入场的
然后这个点我们也是可以入场的符合条件
那我们的止损是设置在我们的这个中线这里也就是这根白色的线这里白色的线这里那我们的目标可以看到我们的菲波那切的382或者70
702这样一个位置
那这个就是我们做的规则
大家可以看到我们这样一个通过唐其安通道的这样一个入场点
其实是入场非常不错的
非常精准的
基本上吃到了这一波大段
如果你在这个点入场的话
基本上你可以吃到这波大段
这个点也是可以的
如果你错过了这个点
这个点也是不错的
所以说这样一个唐前安通道
帮我们在顺势的这样一个交易中
确定了一个非常好的这样一个点位
配合非波拉切
可以把我们的出场入场
做到非常精准
那这个就是我们的做多的一个
好 接着我们来看做空的一个规则
做空的规则是
第一个就是我们要突破确认
这是一个15分钟的一个图
然后价格由上向下
我们突破了这个中线
这个中线就是这个白色的线
然后它如果是趋势变向下的话
它会变成红色
所以这是一个中轨的线
我们可以看到
然后我们的趋势确认就是
中线颜色由我们的这样一个白色变为红色
大家可以看一下红色是吧
就是这样一个我们的空头的颜色
然后我们的入场点在哪里呢
我们的入场点就是
要我们的反弹至中线上方的第一根菲布拉切
也就是说这个菲布拉切线上面的382的这个位置
所以这个点就是我们的一个卖空的一个点
然后这个点也是我们的卖空的一个点
否则这个条件
我们的这个止损设置
可以设置在我们的
这样一个红线的
这样一个上方就可以了
设置在这个上方
然后我们的目标点位是
我们的我们的这个底下
菲布拉切的702和786的
这样一个位置
所以基本上这样一步的话
它整个麦克风的话
这样一个波段
它是也是知道的
而且这个波段的下降幅度
还是非常大的
好这个就是我们的一个规则
如果你也想学习
用Deep Seek
开发出更好的策略
或者零基础
去做这种量化的话
大家可以看我置顶视频
然后或者私信我也可以
好谢谢大家